[Music]
all right so i have a
interesting story from new delhi uh
india india yes i don't know you
pronounce the age
delhi delhi oh yeah that's new delhi
yeah i thought it was new delhi too i'm
stupid don't don't listen to me
don't ask me the names of the people in
this is that where sandwiches come from
do your best go go we'll call her it's
it's 17 letters but we'll just say bala
her name is bala
bala oh no kumar kumar ku kumar oh nat
kumar that's that's what's in there all
right you know a
74 year old man was presumed dead by
his family he lives with his 70 year old
brother
and his uh brother's daughter
oh now he brothers daughter
okay yes yeah his niece niece yes
her name is actually denise in this
there we go
denise denise he's presumed dead the
family
thinking that he's dead they order a
freezer box and i
i first i thought it was like a freezer
freezer like uh
you know for food and stuff but from
like frigidaire
but it's yeah exactly this is my samsung
freezer box
it's got a touch screen on it but it's
actually a freezer box for
dead bodies like a mortuary a
mortician's freezer boxes i ship those
off amazon now
oh yeah two day overnight shipping yeah
ah that's good to know if you have a
dead body
that's did you research this no i just
stopped here clearly sarcastic people
clearly sarcastic but just google it
though check it out all right so
presumed dead they bring in the freezer
box they put the body in the freezer box
that's legal
in india so i don't know i think
everything's in here
i don't know what the protocols are but
this is what happened with this
particular family i'm getting ready for
that deli meat
that new daily me baby but yeah so
um and for whatever reasons the cops
don't come to pick up the dead body
that same night they got tired so they
waited pretty much one full
day they're eating indian donuts and the
next evening
they come to pick up the dead body in
the freezer box
they take it all the way to the mortuary
and upon
arriving there they realize the body
inside the freezer box
is still breathing oh how did they
survive
in that cold freezer exactly that woke
him up maybe
oh you think he came back from the dead
how did he die maybe he wasn't dead i've
heard stories like that died he died of
heat exhaustion
and they froze them back woke up
i heard a story like that on npr some
guy they thought he was dead
and then he he like woke up in the
corners office like that happens a lot
actually
that's so weird i'm sure it does happen
you know yeah so they don't really go
into
details but they say um the man here he
was bedridden for
the past two months so he was already
ill
and so when he died they just
said oh yeah he's been sick now he's
dead maybe his heart just took a break
yeah his heart was like so low they
couldn't even detect it
that's that happens right you die and
then you come back to life and people go
what was it like on the other side and
then you do this tour yeah
at like different talk shows and they're
like did you see the light it was and
then the
click bait is usually i died and came
back to life yeah that's true
and on the other side it's not what you
think it is it's a freezer
it's a freezer box it's very good it's
cold
so yeah but the cold thing is the
intriguing part because
uh physically you can't sit in a freezer
for a full 24 hours and survive yeah
even if you were alive going into the
freezer after 24 hours being in there
like you should be frozen dead yeah i
think so yeah
your body should not function no more
maybe like shocked him alive
yeah i don't know so that and that's
that's the uh that's the the situation
that the cops are facing now and now the
family themselves
this is a demon and they threw him out
of the whole family
or is it a miracle i don't know are they
facing charges yeah they're fake there's
a case uh that's been registered against
this family uh
under the the certain sex two eights i
don't know why you said they think that
their
negligent conduct to endanger human life
and
and section 336 act endangering life or
personal safety of others
of the indian penal code they were like
what he's still alive
oh no oh my god i thought he was dead
yeah they just did that what is this
what does this man say that was a good
ass nap
yeah he's like get me out of it oh [ __ ]
what if it's so hot in india and he just
felt like he was an ac
oh this is so comfortable
it was only the next evening when the
freezer company people came to collect
it around 7-8 pm
they found out the man inside was still
breathing we were trying to establish
what happened he surely could not have
kept the freezer
or he could not have been kept in the
freezer box for all that time
uh the box was in the house meaning they
think he
actually was out of the box for most of
the time and then went back into the box
is what they're assuming like there's no
way that he is still alive
maybe they didn't plug in the freezer oh
[ __ ] like right before they picked them
up is when they plugged it in they're
like oh power at power outages
and then actually tripped the breaker
and then it just
powered down i don't know so now there's
like maybe
and that the article doesn't actually
state this but all things kind of point
towards the fact that there's a case
against the family
so i'm i'm drawing certain conclusions
that maybe
the cops are thinking the family is
trying to off
the old man maybe tired of his bedridden
ass
oh if we just put him in a freezer he'll
freeze to death and then he'll die
anyway he'll die anyways yeah
and perhaps he was sick for the past two
months
maybe i don't know whatever you know his
age he's 74 years old
74 but his brother is 70 years old so
it's like a household of two
really old men and a younger person
were they even happy that he's back
alive it doesn't really say i think
that's when you know
yeah true if they're like it's a miracle
he's alive
everybody or he's like oh he's a oh he's
what happened
like that's a dead like [ __ ] there's a
there's a good reason why they're
getting charged you know i'm sure they
found something out where they're like
oh yeah
they try to kill but can you really go
to jail for stupidity yeah you can yeah
for sure
absolutely that's most of the reasons
why you go to jail because they were
like yeah we did our job he's all good
do we need to check his heart rate
that's cool don't worry about he's for
sure dad trust me that's what they did
then why does he have a boner right now
this happens when people die that's
that's a thing i'm pretty sure he's dead
and that's his butter hitting the top of
the [ __ ] freezer box damn
yeah i'm thinking they didn't plug it in
that's the only way he could have
survived
yeah i would hope that the family isn't
cruel like that
and wanting to just kill someone like
that i kind of want to climb in a
freezer and see how i could last now
i know i think you could last a minute
it's a david blaine challenge i really
like
the cold uh rooms at costco or
restaurant depot
have you ever how long have you stayed
in one i don't know but it feels good i
tried like a couple minutes it got
really cold
a couple minutes damn you're crazy with
cold weather though yeah but that thing
it really chills you to the bone of the
costco
thing it's like it's strong remember
when we went to the waterfall nick and
we did
when i was doing cold training this guy
he stood under the water it was so cold
it
i don't know i don't i don't know what
degrees it was because i have no frame
of reference
it was really clear you bitched out i
bit i
i tried and i just was like oh my god
but then
the whole time the waterfall is hitting
him and waterfalls hurt
it's heavy it feels like spikes man it's
cool
yeah and joe just like just under the
waterfall for like 15 minutes and i'm
like all right guys i'm gonna walk back
i'm out i was like
two right now i was like 25. you had to
work we had to work
like most people were badass and then
you're like it was like two minutes but
most people could probably do about 30
seconds you got to work your way up like
by the time we did it that was like my
fifth time oh
so each time i try to push myself longer
and longer
and it gets easier and easier it was so
cold it was
freaking cold [ __ ] cold it was like
the middle of like
january too you know yeah it was it was
the melted ice water oh [ __ ]
it felt good was your skin like all red
after
yeah it feels like spikes like it feels
like
needles it's crazy what your body does
afterwards though because when you get
out
and we're walking your body's just hot
yeah yeah it feels
so good it's insane it's the weirdest
thing ever that is weird but i'm not
gonna do it again until joe makes me
when i was 15 uh there was this one time
where my cousin and i we went into this
jacuzzi
and it was like really cold in like
regular weather
outside because it was also nighttime so
it was really cold i love how that feels
when it's all cold and it's all warm in
there yeah so then we go in the jacuzzi
and then she dares me she's like i dare
you to jump in the
in the pool and i was like i'll do it if
you do it and she's like okay let's do
it
and then after the jacuzzi we just jump
in the pool and it literally felt like
jumping in a pool of needles
it was so [ __ ] it was insane like
i've never felt that pain ever again but
i know exactly what you mean because
then after we got out
then we jumped back into the it's too
hot yeah it was way too hot
no matter what and then i got sick
afterwards no
wait you should got pneumonia afterwards
i got sick i don't know what i said
oh i got sick we were we were i'm i'm
kind of pissed that you guys actually
did this challenge on jk party
and none of y'all got sick but i was
just the ice bucket one yeah and i i
mean the ice bath yeah the ice bath one
yeah the relay race ice bath thing
uh and i was testing this game and i
literally got sick
literally right afterwards and missed
the shoot they didn't even get to be
there
on the day you guys were doing it and
none of y'all got sick i'm like did you
know that
that one the temperature things have
nothing to do
with sickness so i was just going to get
sick anyways regardless
well your it your symptoms showing is
actually like a week into it
or like like i mean we've been no we we
kind of
all learned about it with corona right
like you can be infected
and you don't show symptoms for corona
specifically like
over a week into it right but the flu is
like three days or like a regular cold
is like
so you've been having it and your body's
been like what about your body being
shocked or like your immune system
getting shocked
and then yeah and then yeah lowering
then you get sick because like your
immune system is not as strong because
they got shocked from the
temperature because it got weakened and
stuff i'm not too sure about
that but then i'm doing research about
like uh there they did
do studies on temperature and how does
that affect
you from being sick they said it's all
related to virus
or like it's not it's not related to to
to the temperature so so like going
like you know how like mom's like you
know take your jacket
or else you'll get sick yeah like that
that has nothing to do with this
cold is actually good for your body and
because
um our body so like for example right
like when
uh humans we're like hunter-gatherers uh
we adjust with the seasons and and our
bodies made to acclimate to
weather so like if it eases into it but
we're always indoors now so we don't
really feel the elements
so like we're meant to actually
like uh deal with weather in drastic
ways
um and one of the things is they're
saying that
extreme cold is actually good for your
body because of inflammation
and then you know like when you get
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] up with an injury or
whatever right
like let's say you [ __ ] hurt your arm
everyone puts ice packets on
because you're trying to cool down that
area with muscle like muscle pain
swelling
swelling yeah and so if we eat all these
[ __ ] up foods or whatever you know
we're our bodies are kind of like
dealing with it internally and inflamed
so like
cool temperatures actually help maintain
that type of
uh uh like regular tory [ __ ] or whatever
where it's like chilling
inside yeah that reminds me of like like
when i'm on certain diets and like
especially with it's like more of an
eastern
medicine kind of the ideology then it's
like eat cool cold foods right cool
foods
to like stop the inflammation inside or
whatever and
then there's like certain hot foods that
you're supposed to avoid but that's not
temperature based right
yeah but i feel like it's like cool
means like a different thing and then
hot
they they mean acidic and basic that's
what they
are or that it's similar to that concept
when they in chinese medicine when they
say cool or hot
it's not temperature right because
things can be cold or hot based off of
the item
oh i see i see in in eastern medicine
[Music]
[Music]
you